hey guys how's it going it's justine
this is ro hello
oh my goodness we have been having so
much fun today so we also made a video
on rose channel
and then now we're over here making
something a little uh real interesting
so not too long ago we made a video
about little tiny chicken nuggets oh it
does smell
plasticky and a bunch of you guys had
sent us this and said you guys have to
do this
this is a mini s'mores makers more
smaller
s'mores so here's the problem though
this arrived at my doorstep on amazon
with like
my address on it right here no outer box
like this was it and it wasn't sealed
i'm concerned about our safety about our
well-being i mean what if they're like
smuggling stuff in here
i'm hoping that all the pieces are here
i think our fire is in here so that's
good
a little campfire here's our packets
that's what we got you're calling no we
need a screwdriver i am not i oh i got
one
i got a screwdriver and i got an
electric one we don't want one no we
don't need an electric one
we don't want it no this is we just have
one
simple screw i don't know
while she's getting the screwdriver i'm
gonna get our items prepared we've got
our little container here we've got our
little
s'more spatula
this is gonna be really good trust me
you're never gonna want to do a manual
one again
look it's so little yeah but you just oh
just
a little bit just do one little yeah
oh it's too big we need a different way
okay okay
oh my gosh if you have a screwdriver you
might as well have one of these
boom ready to tighten ready for that yes
see just think about how long we would
have been here doing this
how do i turn it on and he got
instructions let me get my glasses
oh look at this when you put in your
little thing
then it lights up what do we do first
oh there's a lot of steps here there's
12 steps oh
hot's my coffee let's see adorable and
that happens a lot oh
oh it's so hot i gotta keep but that's a
nice towel
oh no do you want a blue picnic or a
pink picnic we've accomplished
nothing remove the tray packet oh i
skipped step two
step two that was step three open the
graham cracker packet oh it smells nice
that does smell sweet how many scoops do
we need of this
one and a half of those oh then it just
says mix
well then we're gonna evenly distribute
them
in these four trays oh this is gonna
look good oh i like your nail polish
color that's because this is called
cosmopolitan
i like it but i feel like it kind of
looks like a watermelon
step three complete now we're on a step
four
microwave don't even no do not
no we do not need
this is gonna be great justine you're so
crazy
like it's bro it's 15 seconds okay we'll
put this down
is this on how many seconds 10 seconds
it's not even 15.
it's going
this puppy knows how to do it well there
it is okay this is our chocolate packet
when do we get to use that i thought
this was the heat
it makes you know i wonder we could use
the power drill to mix it
open the marshmallow packet this doesn't
smell like a marshmallow this smells a
marshmallow oh
oh wow wow do you want to mix oh yeah i
mean yeah mixing
here you we just finished okay step six
we're halfway there everybody
halfway there
okay here we go we're gonna be needing
our flicker flicker flame
so it looks like this oh it does oh
hello
so this doesn't really heat up anything
oh it's like a dispenser yeah
whoa so this is like a chocolate button
and this is a marshmallow but it is
like give me the chocolate give me the
marshmallow yeah
it's like a slushie machine okay in goes
our mallow get in there get in there
so silly okay here's the chocolate oh
whoa
chocolate guess i put this on top
oh no oh no it's coming out now
flicker flicker fail clean up the
campfire
oh gosh this looks like a real slushy
machine they always get crazy
we just need like a little thing that
keeps them turning you know keeps the
chocolate nice and smooth keeps the
marshmallow nice and smooth
this was twelve dollars well it's a
little too intense for this technology
that we have here
step nine is place a single graham
cracker on the campfire spatula all
right
look at that looks like a little pizza
oven looks like a lie
what do we do first chocolate or
marshmallow i think on us some more when
you got a graham cracker
you put your little chocolate bar down
and then the marshmallow
on top that's awesome so you could do
chocolate first
okay go go oh whoa that's a nice oh
that's a lot of chocolate i'm gonna
ready marshmallow oh there we go oh boy
that's a lot
remove the spatula from the center this
is the 12th step everybody we have
arrived final step
remove it and place another graham
cracker on
the top this is the prettiest graham
cracker so i'm gonna put this one on the
top
there it is i guess we should make
another one so we can both try them
yeah justine i mean i need one chocolate
chocolate chocolate chocolate chocolate
chocolate
boom and a little bit of marshmallow
not really in the mood for a lot of
marshmallow and then i'll just pick this
little sandwich up and
and look at us let's just do a
comparison ours look better
[Laughter]
full of lies you want to get a box of
lies this is what you gotta get
justine's very upset because she i love
s'mores
and it doesn't look like the picture
well let's have this
delectable look oh yeah cheat oh my gosh
mine's i feel like you got all the
chocolate there because you mean do you
want this one
he's like a little song that one looks
better like anyone trying
no it's fine okay okay here we go
i kind of like classic s'mores a little
more but it does yeah i mean it does
taste like chocolate
it's just really a very mushy
cracker it's not a cracker yeah i think
um
it does taste like some more but it's
the it's the texture
it's yeah it's kind of squishy tastes
like a s'more but the texture is squishy
see look at these i'm interested to see
what this stuff tastes like
it may taste like graham cracker or
crust this is the marshmallow
yeah this stinks let's taste this one
that didn't taste like a marshmallow oh
i think we're done here done we have
just
lies oh i will say these are actually
really fun to make
yeah i had so much fun making them i had
a lot of fun making these and they did
kind of taste like us some more only the
texture was just super
weird and squishy i mean you can't
really expect much from like
a powder yeah i thought like it would be
like astronaut meals where you add water
and it's like
poop there's potatoes oh i'm getting an
aftertaste from that
marshmallow yeah that's that's
definitely ground up plastic
for sure i was hoping i was really
hoping that this would cook stuff like a
little easy bake or something
yeah this is not a fun cleanup no it's
just a
parents dispenser machine you're not
going to want to clean those later
but it lights up it's true and i had a
great time making this with you so
i had a great time making these with you
so thanks so much for joining me
and thanks for letting me use your setup
justine if you need to come over and
build something do it here i got
everything
i got microwaves i've got power tools i
just got a leaf blower the other week
couple weeks ago
i've got everything it's true she really
got it over
we also made a super fun video on rose's
channel so go check that out i'll put a
link in the description
and annotations where you guys can go
check that out and that's it we did it
dinner okay cool
well that's uh that's all we'll see you
guys next video bye
[Music]
ah
you